my fellow Americans tonight I am
speaking to you because there is a
growing humanitarian and security crisis
at our southern border every day Customs
and Border Patrol agents encounter
thousands of illegal immigrants trying
to enter our country we are out of space
to hold them and we have no way to
promptly return them back home to their
country America proudly welcomes
millions of lawful immigrants who enrich
our society and contribute to our nation
but all Americans are hurt by
uncontrolled illegal migration it
strains public resources and drives down
jobs and wages among those hardest hit
are African Americans and Hispanic
Americans our southern border is a
pipeline for vast quantities of illegal
drugs including meth heroin cocaine and
fentanyl every week 300 of our citizens
are killed by heroin alone 90% of which
floods across from our southern border
more Americans will die from drugs this
year than were killed in the entire
Vietnam War in the last two years ice
officers made 266 thousand arrests of
aliens with criminal records including
those charged or convicted of 100,000
assaults 30,000 sex crimes and 4,000
violent killings over the years
thousands of Americans have been
brutally killed by those who illegally
entered our country and thousands more
lives will be lost if we don't act right
now this is a humanitarian crisis a
crisis of the heart and a crisis of the
soul
last month 20,000 migrant children were
illegally brought into the United States
a dramatic increase these children are
used as human pawns by vicious
Odie's and ruthless gangs one in three
women are sexually assaulted on the
dangerous trek up through Mexico women
our children are the biggest victims by
far of our broken system this is the
tragic reality of illegal immigration on
our southern border this is the cycle of
human suffering that I am determined to
end my administration has presented
Congress with a detailed proposal to
secure the border and stop the criminal
gangs drug smugglers and human
traffickers it's a tremendous problem
our proposal was developed by law
enforcement professionals and border
agents at the Department of Homeland
Security these are the resources they
have requested to properly perform their
mission and keep America safe in fact
safer than ever before the proposal from
Homeland Security includes cutting-edge
technology for detecting drugs weapons
illegal contraband and many other things
we have requested more agents
immigration judges and bed space to
process the sharp rise and unlawful
migration fueled by our very strong
economy our plan also contains an urgent
request for humanitarian assistance and
medical support furthermore we have
asked Congress to close border security
loopholes so that illegal immigrant
children can be safely and humanely
returned back home finally as part of an
overall approach to border security law
enforcement professionals have requested
5.7 billion dollars for a physical
barrier at the request of Democrats it
will be a steel barrier rather than a
concrete wall this barrier is absolutely
critical to border security it's also
what our professionals at the border
want and need
this is just common sense the border
wall would very quickly pay for itself
the cost of illegal drugs exceeds 500
billion dollars a year vastly more than
the 5.7 billion dollars we have
requested from Congress the wall will
also be paid for indirectly by the great
new trade deal we have made with Mexico
Senator Chuck Schumer who you will be
hearing from later tonight has
repeatedly supported a physical barrier
in the past along with many other
Democrats they change their mind
only after I was elected president
Democrats in Congress have refused to
acknowledge the crisis and they have
refused to provide our brave border
agents with the tools they desperately
need to protect our families and our
nation the federal government remains
shut down for one reason and one reason
only because Democrats will not fund
border security my administration is
doing everything in our power to help
those impacted by the situation but the
only solution is for Democrats to pass a
spending bill that defends our borders
and reopens the government this
situation could be solved in a 45-minute
meeting I have invited congressional
leadership to the White House tomorrow
to get this done hopefully we can rise
above partisan politics in order to
support national security some have
suggested a barrier is immoral then why
do wealthy politicians build walls
fences and gates around their homes they
don't build walls because they hate the
people on the outside but because they
love the people on the inside the only
thing that is immoral is the politicians
to do nothing and continue to allow more
innocent people to be so horribly
victimized America's heart broke the day
after Christmas when a young police
officer in California was savagely
murdered in cold blood by an illegal
alien just came across the border the
life of an American Hero was stolen by
someone who had no right to be in our
country
day after day precious lives are cut
short by those who have violated our
borders in California an Air Force
veteran was raped murdered and beaten to
death with a hammer by an illegal alien
with a long criminal history in Georgia
an illegal alien was recently charged
with murder for killing beheading and
dismembering his neighbor in Maryland
ms-13 gang members who arrived in the
United States as unaccompanied minors
were arrested and charged last year
after viciously stabbing and beating a
16 year old girl over the last several
years I've met with dozens of families
whose loved ones were stolen by illegal
immigration
I've held the hands of the weeping
mothers and embraced the grief-stricken
fathers so sad so terrible I will never
forget the pain in their eyes the
tremble in their voices and the sadness
gripping their souls
how much more American blood must we
shed before Congress does its job for
those who refuse to compromise in the
name of border security
I would ask imagine if it was your child
your husband or your wife whose life was
so cruelly shattered and totally broken
for every member of Congress
pass a bill that ends this crisis to
every citizen call Congress and tell
them to finally after all of these
decades secure our border this is a
choice between right and wrong justice
and injustice this is about whether we
fulfill our sacred duty to the American
citizens we serve when I took the oath
of office I swore to protect our country
and that is what I will always do so
help me God
thank you and good night